[Music]
fifty-two seconds of logos hey it's Josh
Holloway which you've lost her Aerosmith
videos have taught me anything means
he's a scoundrel and or a bad guy here
these guys completely miss him
but he hits both of them Wow Ollie I
don't know I see a hot lady walking down
an alley after I just did some super spy
I'd probably be suspicious but maybe
they don't teach the danger of boners
it's by school wow that text about this
possible assassin actually killed him by
distracting him from the actual assassin
later we find out that Hannah weighs
fancy contacts recognized Sabine's face
and send a message to his phone which
distracts him here and gets him killed
but later we find out he can see that
without looking at his phone so what the
fuck Ethan Hunt is addicted was sleeping
cellmates this prisoner is suddenly
emboldened just because his cell door
mysteriously open why does he think he's
got the upper hand
why does some of these cells have one
dude and others have two dudes and this
room has four dudes in it this prison is
making it up as it goes along
Ethan improvises to break out one of his
buddies during a highly sensitive Prison
Break plant he's so confident in his
skills a massive chaotic fight in a tiny
space doesn't worry him and the ability
to tow a completely untrained person
back through it isn't given a second
thought as the movie establishes the
song ain't that a kick in the head is 2
minutes and 24 seconds a duration which
has already elapsed yeah better not show
how Ethan got out of this because it
would be bull anyway luckily every
prisoner on this level was absolutely
ready and waiting by their doors as soon
as it opened
Dean Martin's classic song ends 90
seconds after it was supposed to end
also there wasn't any real reason other
than pure sanity logic and reason of
course the ethan needed to be here when
the song ended there would've been no
consequence to him being late as long as
Ethan continued to beat ass like he
normally does because the hole would
have been waiting for him when he got
there haha this is the fuse we'd see in
a Naked Gun movie spoiling the credits
Paula Patton is damn simply not my
girlfriend I am a failure what the fuck
is he doing it looked like he was trying
to find Moreau but he's just standing
there pointing his gun it nothing in
particular
Moreau just left the scene to Intel
suggests cobalt is already in route
leaving you four hours 52 minutes to
infiltrate 4 hours and 52 minutes to
infiltrate the Kremlin sounds legit so
they went from hi 8 tapes to HD oakley
sunglasses to codec instant cameras to
dirty ass payphones with digital iPad
screens Jesus imf's mission delivery
tech department is all over the place
yeah better make sure this message
self-destruct god knows how many people
out there have even's eyes know the code
e punched in and could stumble on this
payphone figuring out all sorts of
secrets
Jesus Christ why didn't you idiots just
send Paula Patton in 10 minutes earlier
and remove this tension completely it's
absolutely bonkers that the IMF didn't
send another person with way more
experience than Benjie to be part of
this team we're talking nuclear launch
codes here priority number one on their
list and they send a guy who just
recently became an agent any tech
security camera companies can come up
with is always instantly rendered moot
with the placement of a simple device
mirror or a can of spray paint oh good
they managed to bring a screen that is
exactly the size of the opening of this
Kremlin hallway that's especially
amazing since Benjy and Jane didn't even
know they were going to the Kremlin when
they broke Ethan out of prison also it's
pretty fantastic that no one ever walks
through here that they can do this
undetected from behind
ok this technology may be bulbous hell
but I don't give a shit the scene is
tense comical and plot-related
and I'm giving this movie two cents off
for this stuff well how many noises is
this guy gonna be distracted by he just
got back to a seat from investigating
the last phantom noise have you made it
to the archive room how do you broadcast
on all signals including this Kremlin
secure channel and the IMF secure
channel Ethan doesn't think much of this
guy now but is pretty sure Hendricks is
behind all this when he turns the corner
and sees the safe open so why doesn't he
follow it this guy of all people would
know where to go to be safe from the
explosion and Ethan's no slouch in the
beating ass department so it's extremely
strange he lets this guy go Hey look Tom
Cruise is running fast again man I'm
starting to wonder if maybe he does this
more than riding motorcycles and movies
Ethan out runs these explosions like
he's the goddamn Starship Enterprise
here's yet another explode
that merely knocks Ethan to one side of
the other instead of rightfully killing
his fool ass
ah I see Ethan saw Terminator 2 why are
somehow perfectly positioned coming out
of this random spot of the hospital for
Ethan to do this how did this asshole
and his henchmen get in here grab the
mom and kid and make sure they didn't
scream all without making noise
themselves European male 50's about
six-foot 180 pounds blue eyes who is he
well that description and your crude
hand drawing probably means only one
person could be weeks before the
Russians know it's missing unless we
tell them they won't listen to us yeah
so it's better to just not tell them
because who believes in covering all
bases and why would the Russians do
something smart like changing their
launch codes just in case the Americans
might not be bullying them as far as the
Russians are concerned we just bombed
the Kremlin but why because one American
was found outside in the debris because
it's still the Cold War because the plot
demands a resident is initiated ghost
Protocol roll credits how does this miss
them besides that I thought Bullitt
slowed down quite a bit when they hit
one or anyway is it anyway what is
naughty boy of the future today
really he escaped prison then planned
the Kremlin mission then got knocked
down from the explosion then escaped the
hospital and had this car ride with IMF
peeps all in one day why would that work
Frant please the pronoun game so that
Ethan has to ask what that means Clare
on the body
what were their work you might think we
believe Brandt would be excellent at
cinemasins but in this case no of course
the guys with guns would shoot at it why
wouldn't they are they gonna believe
even set up a dead body as a diversion
we would have said it if they somehow
knew not to shoot at it
movies attempt to defend itself in this
case even cheekily is unnecessary
luckily this thing has a couple handle
bars right next to it just in case you
need to hold yourself steady while being
scanned
why would benji and jane think anyone
other than an IMF agent could get into
this car with a fucking retinal scanner
outside why does this video look like
something i used to play on the Sega CD
back in the 90s until indicates she'll
check in at the burj hotel in dubai 36
hours you would have thought it would
have been difficult to find an assassin
like her in two days but she was as easy
to find as Shaquille O'Neal in a sea of
Peter Dinklage's also why hasn't Murrow
already sold these launch codes she took
them two days ago and it's gonna be
another couple of days before she sells
them to Hendrix because IMF agents
always have time we shut down no
satellites safehouse support works fresh
only this super high-tech train with all
the weapons and gear we could possibly
need that's all we have an hour
suppose how do we keep them in separate
rooms while having them think that
they're in the same room this is a
question Brent actually asked back on
the train while they were planning this
mission but they asked him to hold it
until now for expositional purposes and
come on Ethan didn't see that in the
road 34 minutes the door knock Brandt
sets his obvious iPhone down propped up
against Benji's obvious MacBook Air to
ensure perfect product placement feng
shui
if you've seen this zoom in and over the
Burj Khalifa shot in IMAX like I did you
know exactly why I'm taking a sin off
here all right none of the people in
these rooms reporting a man climbing
outside their 120 plus story window
glove begins to malfunction for the sake
of the scenes tension Ethan falls this
far
but the movie glosses over is climbed
back up like it's nothing by the way
despite having cop notch security in
this room
Bert hotel decides that no determined
person could ever come through the glass
and doesn't put an alarm on it what
happens with innocent people with rooms
in this hotel get to their floor and
find out they're on the wrong one what
if they decide to go up one floor and
find out their floor has seemingly been
erased from existence some sort of cable
thing of a bomb just happens to be in
the secure server area so that Ethan can
escape this is where a motherfucker is
dead just from the impact alone but of
course movie will sell an outline of
goods about people being able to catch a
falling person without being pulled down
themselves just because Jane grabs a
piece of carpet all of this at a split
second of thought by the way was only
let me get this straight IMF was
tracking Wistrom knew his every move and
knew where he was coming today but they
didn't know that he had a Russian launch
code verification guy with him you guys
knew exactly who you needed to make
masks for but you wait until the last
minute to start the process why not on
the train ridiculously detail-oriented
super spy Ethan Hunt forgets he has his
goggles around his neck because he's
going to need them later during the
sandstorm scene earlier we saw Benji
changing the numbers on the doors so
that the bad guys would go into the
wrong room
but even though Benji has control of the
elevators there isn't any explanation
that he can fool the elevator into
displaying the wrong floor this is from
a movie that tells us every other aspect
of the plant
come on first off I know we can see it
since the camera is getting an extreme
closeup of his eye but how can she from
where she's sitting second off slick
super spy is somehow this easily
detectable just by looking at it these
Russian guys basically derail Ethan's
covert surveillance which would be
interesting if it wasn't completely
unbelievable that two Rando Russian
intelligence officers deduced that Ethan
boarded a magic IMF train and ended up
in motherfucking Dubai does divine
suddenly have a share all video
surveillance treaty with Russia this is
a lazy excuse to let the guy Eaton's
chasing know he's being chased and
nothing else
fight gives character who wanted to
murder someone for revenge and non
revenge reason to murder that person
this guy was going fast enough to cause
Ethan to break the windshield but Ethan
it's made of titanium at this point so
it doesn't hurt him also why the would
you drive that fast in a sandstorm when
you can't see ethan bails out of the car
going over fifty miles an hour and
suffers no consequences even if he knows
for a fact who you are after pulling off
a piece of that mask earlier what's the
freaking point the sandstorm knows where
the drama's headed max's henchmen from
the first movie got out of prison and
just happens to work for the one guy
ethan needs to give him information and
it's using the same covert travelling
techniques Brandt's backstory super
coincidentally involves Ethan Hunt and
his supposedly dead wife which is extra
weird
given how accidentally Brandt came to be
part of Ethan's current crew I certainly
cannot tell you that Russia acquired
this old and obsolete technical
satellite to a sudden telecom and Mumbai
Ethan had to convince his prison buddy
to convince this arms dealer to come to
Dubai and he just happens to have the
exact information Ethan needs that
certainly couldn't have been any other
arms dealer in the world who had this
information this entire operation relies
on Jane being the hottest most alluring
woman at this party which I admit is
kind of hard to fault but how do we know
how they berry isn't wandering around or
Selena Gomez
did I say Selena Gomez I met Betty White
sorry about that well I like to toys
movie rips off and updates the mr. pink
argument from Reservoir Dogs why is
there a convenient tunnel for this thing
to drive through from this electrical
room impressed yet but this scenes
motivation Paula Patton was forced to
pretend her popstar husband had cheated
on her and she was after revenge Saturn
take two leap by the way why can't he do
what Ethan did in the other Mission
Impossible movies and just have some
climbers cables and rappel down the
tunnel could me at least do that instead
of jumping 25 feet to his possible death
then use the cool magnet thing later all
this thick metal everywhere and that
magnet thing still keeps Brandt floating
in the air and not only that there's a
perfect path carved out for him to go
anywhere he wants it's downloaded a
virus from I thought pendrick's can only
operate the satellite from this central
server but apparently you can just go
uplink anywhere
send a virus from the satellite and
destroy the central server and still
have control of the damn thing but the
question is if you can do that why does
he even need to do anything to that
particular server oh this manoeuvre
couldn't been more convenient not only
did he miss that killer turbine it even
blew him closer to the ventilation shaft
[Music]
well my frustration at seeing Ethan
escape requires the undoing of my time
my relief and having escaped requires
the undoing of my time La Crosse's
Central Command after the system Jesus
you can do everything from this Mumbai
TV station Kane long until Hendrix could
launch a missile that sounds like it
will be impossible to stop but didn't
Hendrix already have launch capability
when we last saw him what does he have
to wait for overly long launch sequence
cliche but didn't we just hear he could
launch a missile in 30 seconds why are
there all these extra time jumps before
he can actually launch the missile this
guy calls a military submarine and gives
some orders and shockingly the submarine
follows them Jesus even in the Hunt for
Red October the Russians had several
checks and balances in place in terms of
boats orders that's why Rania's had to
kill the KGB officer there has to be a
way to avert the warhead if there is why
he'll be on the launch device we're
gonna get that case I'm confused isn't
the lunch device the fucking submarine
or we literally saw dudes turn missile
keys and launch the missile why is the
case even called a lunch device when he
made a phone call to get that missile
launch like I said I'm confused then she
runs to the glass door and opens it to
continue running instead of shooting his
legs through the glass immediately to
take him down Tom Cruise runs really
fast past a bunch of motorcycles this
fight goes on far too long for one that
includes Ethan Hunt and a really old
pudgy dude honestly I feel like I could
have gotten this case by now I know he's
hurt but it's like both of these guys
are coated in butter during this entire
scene bran forgets how to agent and
allows this dumbass and an easily
detectable hiding place to get the drop
on him I mean where did you think that
guy was gonna be anyway obvious dummy is
obvious that is a terrible idea and of
course he survives he should have just
jumped airbags are not beanbag chairs
this clock is of course total nonsense
the fact that this guy has any life in
him at all this decayed a shot square in
the back even though Benji is shooting
from the side hospital why you're
Wolverine aren't you your face doesn't
have a mark on it after taking the brunt
of an airbag deployment from a dead drop
head-on crash with a concrete floor at
many miles per hour
whatever's broke now will have healed
itself by the time you get to the
hospital right I got away with that
cover story after it hit a queen
building in the age of surveillance and
cell phone cameras and HD everything
Ving Rhames has given me a cameo status
at the end of this movie
dumb luck was it yes it was to the end
to fake your wife's death as long as
we're together she'll never be safe I
just don't see how that can be true if
you work at the CIA aren't there all
sorts of options to keep you protected
plus I don't know how you continue to do
this kind of work if you're so easy to
identify or locate surprise cameo it's
not really all that surprising if you've
seen a couple of movies before but oh
well I'm glad I have this weird
arrangement that doesn't make any sense
those crazy kids
[Music]
we have a passenger
no diamonds no codes no tickee no
laundry house was cursed she made us get
a count again the curse rebus love the
jet where do you see the car to club the
car
it's a 25-foot drop and we're using
magnets take a big step back and
literally your advice don't burden
yourself with these secrets of scary
people welcome back to Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire they're feeling our missiles
we're fighting an army of robots and
have a bow and arrow none of this makes
sense